don't know I know you are a true Disney
fanatic I'll provide a voice on Star
Wars resistance are just streaming now
on Disney Plus so how broke are you to
be one of the first to ride the new Star
Wars rise the resistance right it's
already open in Disney World but opens
tomorrow here at Disneyland I'll just
say this it's always great when you
first
yeah Raisa the resistance had me feeling
all sorts of ways childlike wonder
misplaced anger but mostly pure
white-knuckle fun
yeah I'm gonna cried at the end but I'd
do it again and luckily I had this
adorable little guide it gives me a
pick-me-up
hey thank you you're doing so good we're
in trouble work we gotta go
Disney's also unveiling an all-new
parade next month called magic happens
my fav this Moana flow what if that guy
will sound like the rocks it's also got
an original song by Taylor Swift's
bestie todrick Hall I learned how to
dance from watching the Disney parades
so the fact that I'm getting to create
the music that these iconic Disney
characters are going to be performing to
is kind of the most epic thing that's
ever happened to me in my life
[Music]
assemblé and this summer we're hoping
our DJ Chris Hemsworth and Chris Evans
will all be at the opening of The
Avengers campus at Disney California
Adventure you'll be able to meet all
your favorite marvel super heroes and
even sling webs like spider-man
on an all-new ride I love The Avengers
and I love to go on rides okay well
let's go back on the ride but you need
some noise cancelling earphones if
you're gonna sit next to me though
unfortunately sorry